could you maybe
talk about the difference between the
torah sure
the bible and the quran
so
there's the hebrew bible
is actually what's called a step canon
that is they're the five books of the
torah
then there are books of history and the
prophets
so books like samuel kings judges
and then the prophets isaiah jeremiah
amos ezekiel so on
and then there are what are called the
writings
the writings are books like psalms
proverbs job
the megilot which are esther daniel all
of those all those books um ecclesiastes
so in hebrew it's called the tanakh
torah naveem ketuvim the torah
the
prophets and the writings and that is
the hebrew bible
sometimes that's also called the torah
just to be confusing but really the
torah generally refers to the five books
then
there is the new testament
which the jews don't recognize as a
sacred book
they recognize it as the book of another
religion and i sometimes say to
christians in order for them to really
grasp this
jesus has as much religious significance
to judaism as muhammad has to
christianity that is jesus although
jewish
became the founder of another religion
and for judaism that's not only inasmuch
as christians and jews have had a lot of
interactions but religiously jesus has
no significance
said many beautiful things said some
things i don't like so much like
like what leave your father and mother
and follow me i don't like that as a
religious model
um
now chris the whole thing is pretty
christians will say that i don't
understand that but they but that's
because christians like jews interpret
their texts different ways at different
times so um
anyway
the koran which i know less well i have
read it but i know it less well then i
know the new testament certainly less
well obviously than i know the hebrew
bible
is a very is in some ways a
parts of it are i
i don't say this word i say this word
because i can't find a better
descriptive word but but muslims will
not accept this okay is it take off on
the torah in some things that is it's
the same stories as the torah but
they're different
now jews will say and i being a jew will
say this that that's because muhammad
heard those stories from jews and also
heard midrashim which are rabbinic
interpretations of those stories and he
wrote those down
muslims will say no the jews got it
wrong and muhammad came along to correct
the record and tell the real story but
they're all
telling the story of the same
the hebrew the hebrew bible part the
abrahamic part they all tell the story
of the same characters but tell them the
obviously christians accept the hebrew
bible as sacred scripture um
the muslims
retell
many of the stories in the bible
what is what is common to all of them is
that all of them
are monotheistic faiths now in
christianity that's more complicated
because of the trinity
but
as christianity has developed over time
it clearly
presents itself and thinks of itself and
is a monotheistic faith as well what's
the role of the word in each of these
religions in the scriptures so in terms
of
so first of all oral the role of oral
traditions the power of the exactness of
the words in the scripture does it
differ
or is it really within the communities
of differences differs because
in christianity
the words are not all the words of jesus
they're the words of jesus's disciples
none of the books of the new testament
were written by people who met jesus in
person so they're different and
therefore the and also we don't even
know sometimes the original language of
some of the things
in the new testament
in the bible and i understand in the
quran but i'll speak for the hebrew
bible the idea is that that's lashon
hakodish that's sacred language and
hebrew is in its that's the language
according to the tradition that god
actually spoke to moses and therefore
the exact words are infinitely
interpretable and meaningful
and but the words were spoken by written
by moses and the same with muhammad
right
but from memory
or no there are different there are
different theories i won't speak for
muhammad you should
ask i don't want to get i don't want to
get that wrong i want to get another
religious tradition wrong in judaism the
words are written by moses at god's
dictation basically that's the
traditional view there are other views
that i i'm happy to go into if you want
to but basically that's the traditional
view so it's pretty close right what
makes it different what makes judaism
and christianity different
is christianity has an ideal life
judaism doesn't have an ideal life
judaism has an ideal book so the
holidays of christianity are events in
the life of god
god's birth god's death and resurrection
in judaism
the holidays are all events in the life
of the people like the liberation from
slavery
or in the people's relationship to god
like yom kippur which is a day of
atonement but there are no holidays in
judaism that are events in the life of
god because in judaism god doesn't have
a biography
god is eternal and god never came to
earth
you